when we think about European exploration
in the Americas we tend to start at 1492
with Christopher Columbus showing up at
the island of Hispaniola but in this
video I want to take a step back a few
decades and talk about the conditions
that led to Christopher Columbus's
voyage in the first place what was he
doing there so let's zoom in a little
bit and take a look at what the world
would have looked like to someone in
Western Europe around the Year 1450 so
to a European this would have been about
the extent of the known world now they
wouldn't have had anything like the
level of this detail but they certainly
knew that there were very good things to
be had in India and China and the Middle
East
excellent trade goods like silken spices
and they knew there was quite a lot of
world outside of Europe and Africa but
they didn't think that there was much
out there they expected there would be
some small islands on the range of
Iceland perhaps but they had no
conception that there were two gigantic
continents on the other side of the
Atlantic Ocean
it's a frequent misconception that
people in this time period thought that
the world was flat learn it people of
the era knew that the world was round in
fact they had known so since the time of
the Greeks what they did know was that
the world was pretty large in fact they
correctly estimated that the
circumference of the globe is about 25
thousand miles and so they knew that
given the shipping technology that they
had it would be impossible to go west
and arrive at the East while still
having enough food and water to supply
your crew now why would anyone have
dreamt of going West to get
when they could have simply gone east to
get east well the answer is that the
over land route was long and it was
expensive because the Middle East and
North Africa and even parts of Spain
were controlled by Muslim empires like
the Ottomans and the Moors and so
anytime trade came from the East China
India Middle East itself it went through
a series of traders and a series of
empires along the way picking up taxes
and markups which meant that by the time
a good reached Western Europe it was
pricey indeed and since Muslim traders
were in control of the Mediterranean
here and at the East taking a ship
through their cause pretty much the same
problem so why not go around the coast
of Africa well that was certainly
something that Europeans were keen to do
the only problem is that the wind goes
in the wrong direction as a very
treacherous sailing around the tip of
Africa to come up into the Indian Ocean
so what changed how did this Overland
trade route become an oversea trade
route well for that we have to look a
little bit closer at the Iberian
Peninsula
so this landmass here is the Iberian
Peninsula and at the time the Iberian
Peninsula was controlled by a number of
different groups the southern part was
under Muslim control of the Moors as
they were called or Moroccan Muslims and
they called this area al Andaluz
talking about this area here and the
Spanish called it Granada the western
part here was under the control of
Portugal as it is today Portugal the
eastern part this area here is the
kingdom of Aragon and then the central
part here was kingdom of Castile so as
far as Europeans were concerned this was
kind of the end of the world this was as
far southwest as you could go on the
European continent and heaven knows what
was out here until in the early 1400s
Portugal's Prince Henry the Navigator
began investing in navigation and one of
the important discoveries made by the
Portuguese was a new kind of ship and
the ship was called the caravel so
what's cool about the Caravelle is that
caravels are Ocean worthy but they're
also very easy to maneuver and they can
sail into the wind so that means that
the problems of sailing around Africa
begin to get a little bit easier and so
in this early era of the 1400s the
Portuguese began expanding their
exploration farther and farther down the
coast of Africa and they come across
these islands now that they don't have
to hug the coast the Canary Islands and
farther west this is so small you can
barely see it here Madeira
and the Azores and they quickly discover
that these islands are ideal places to
grow cash crops specifically sugar they
also discover that some of the people
who live on these islands fact the
Canary Islands had a native population
called the Guanche a they immediately
attempted to enslave these native people
and then quickly discovered that they
would die of disease well talk more
about why native people seemed to be so
susceptible to European diseases a
little bit later so now they have great
places to grow sugar but they don't have
a workforce well they're discovering
another workforce along the coast of
Africa as they begin to set up this is
the Portuguese we're talking about here
trading posts on the west coast of
Africa where they're purchasing slaves
from African traders or Arab traders who
had a long history of trading slaves
from the interior of Africa out to its
coasts so in the early 1400s Portugal is
doing very well for itself seems that
they're leading this colonial game
they've pretty much invented the
plantation system and they're getting
quite wealthy off of it so the eyes of
Europe turned to Portugal and they think
all right how can we replicate their
success meanwhile back on the Iberian
Peninsula there is a political and
religious shake-up so the kingdoms of
Castile and Aragon are united when
Ferdinand of Aragon and Isabella of
Castile and I recognized that my Spanish
pronunciation is terrible they get
married in 1469 and unite their two
kingdoms into
what becomes the kingdom of Spain so
what had been Castile and Aragon becomes
Spain and then United these two Catholic
Monarchs turn their attentions to what's
called the Reconquista so re conquering
the territories that had been controlled
by Muslims for Christians so I call this
kind of an extension of Crusader
thinking and Ferdinand and Isabella
complete the Reconquista expelling the
Moors from the territory that is today's
Spain in 1492 so now we've reached 1492
and we've got a will that is a desire
for luxury goods we also have a little
bit of good old-fashioned nationalism
here Spain's closest neighbor is
Portugal who are currently very powerful
and wealthy so they've got perhaps some
rivalry in their hearts and we've got a
way which is the caravel that is making
more and more ocean sailing possible and
into this exciting moment steps
Christopher Columbus and we'll talk more
about him in the next video